General Grievous Asaj Ventress even
Count Dooku
to face any one of them on the
battlefield
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my full Ahsoka episode 7 video
there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
in references so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes this is obviously building up
to the Mandalorian season 4 I'll be
doing videos for that soon in Ahsoka
season two which they were working on
before the strike which is now pretty
much over thankfully thankfully they've
worked out most of the strike stuff they
still have the actor strike to resolve
but that sounds like it's gonna happen
in the next couple of weeks and things
will slowly get back to normal by the
middle of October we're doing the
giveaway for the Mandalorian Blu-rays
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just post all your
predictions for the finale in the
comments I think we can all agree that
thrawn will make it back to the main
Galaxy and they'll end on some kind of
WTF Avengers Infinity War kind of
cliffhanger like thanos's Snap in
starting his new star war against the
New Republic but careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened on Ahsoka
so far if you haven't seen the episode
yet but basically thrawn is the Thanos
of the new Star Wars universe so to
speak everything that's happening on
Ahsoka now that will build up in the
mandalorians and four and maybe Ahsoka
season 2 before the thrawn movie or
maybe right after the thrawn movie is
meant to build up to that thrawn movie
so that when they begin that movie they
can begin kind of like the beginning of
Revenge of the Sith in the middle of a
giant battle with thrawn's forces
against the New Republic so like a lot
of Ahsoka here is basically to build up
to thrawn making it back in the finale
is him actually making it back probably
the actual episode title was dreams and
Madness which is a reference to the
Nightsisters ability to see through
the force what they call the dream they
perceive things through time and space
in what they call the dream space it's
how Morgan elsbest was able to
communicate with the Nightsisters
great mothers across galaxies basically
just another way that they're able to
use the force in a different way from
traditional Jedi or traditional Sith
there are a lot of different cultures
that all draw upon the force in
different ways the title might also be a
reference to thrawn and Baylan Skoll
separate Grand plans they both have
these crazy plans but we still don't
know enough about bailin's plan yet
apparently they're waiting to the finale
to reveal what power it is on the planet
that's been calling to him through the 4
course I've already had a couple
theories about this that might have
something to do with the night sister
ancient ruins written on the side of
their Temple zoom and enhance the
language that they're written in is uric
attack which is an old Sith language
it's basically the Sith alphabet and was
only spoken by members of the Sith
Empire recently a fan translated the
runes from Ur-Kittat this ancient Sith
language and they praise kujet
ruler of all may his Reign last for all
time
we've reached the tomb of Kujet
of an astrum so the whole idea is that
this kujet figure that's mentioned on
the Nightsisters Temple wall in the
other Galaxy was part of the Zeffo race
who they featured during the Jedi Fallen
Order Jedi Survivor games during the
height of the zepho Empire long before
the days of the Old Republic he was a
powerful Dark Side Sage as part of their
race who created a temple on dathomir
that Cal Kestis is exploring here that
Merrin has been protecting so this might
be the power that Baylan Skoll feels
calling to him on parity like the
remnants of kujet's four spirit that
remained alive these many many tens of
thousands of years the actual episode
starts back on Coruscant during the
inquest that they're breaking hair over
the coals for going rogue on them trying
to basically kick her out of the
military give her a dishonorable
discharge that same Senator
Xiono is the one who really has it out
for they want to remove her command
basically and it sounds like he's doing
a lot of things here for political
purposes just maneuvering politically
they really want to make him seem like a
dirtbag but I don't actually think that
he's an Empire loyalist like I don't
think he's still working with the shadow
Council or anything like that just
because he denies them so vehemently I
think the idea is he's just meant to be
a plain old the evidence of
thrawn coming back that he denies will
be here soon enough like thrawn will
show up and be like okay maybe you were
right about that but when Carson Teva
shows up shaking his head means that he
doesn't have any sign of ahsoka's return
or Morgan ellisbeth to the hyperspace
ring they're still in that other Galaxy
so like they don't have the hard proof
that the Senators are asking for he also
reminds them about what happened with
moth Gideon during the Mandalorian
season 1 through season three in the new
Republic Mosley believes that he was
acting alone like everything that
happened on Mandalore that Force he was
gathering they think that he was by
himself they do not believe that the
shadow Council exists to her credit
though mon mothma at least seems like
she believes hair like how real is this
thrawn thing okay pretty real okay we
need to be worried right now then we get
our next really big Cameo scene when
C-3PO comes in saying that he's come on
behalf of Princess Leia to speak on
Hera's behalf because Leia has such a
long relationship with the Star Wars
Rebels characters working with them
she's been friends with them for a long
time since well before A New Hope if you
haven't watched any of those Star Wars
Rebels episodes she showed up in the
Rebels episodes a whole bunch of times
we're from Phoenix Squadron I Know Who
You Are and unless you want the deck
officer to know too I suggest you put
your helmets back on and keep your mouth
shut excuse me she covers for Hera by
saying she authorized the mission and
they also clarify that at least right
now in the new Republic she's the leader
of their Defense Force or the defense
Council which is basically like the
military arm of the new Republic
Princess Leia also throws a bunch of
shade at Senator ziono by saying that he
basically held this vote without her
which he needed to do because hair is
part of the military and she controls
the military and it sounds like Senator
ziono might be her political rival
inside the new Republic notice Chopper
in the background while this is going on
just cursing up a storm in Droid anytime
you see Chopper in scenes unless he's
answering something in like a yes no
kind of question he's usually cursing
part of the Princess Leia stuff here is
also to lay some seeds for stuff that
happens during the force awakens so the
whole idea is that she's the leader of
the defense counsel in the new Republic
now but eventually years later a senator
inside the new Republic who was a rival
of hers and it sounds like it's probably
going to be Senator ziono outed her that
she was the daughter of of Darth Vader
to everybody else in the new Republic I
think the ideas that he was trying to
use that knowledge to maneuver around
her politically so Leia basically gave
them the finger left the new Republic to
develop the resistance with help from
people that were still inside the new
Republic but a lot of that stuff won't
happen till like way later in the
timeline then we get our next big Cameo
scene Anakin Skywalker comes back Ahsoka
continues practicing her lightsaber
techniques while listening to a hologram
of Anakin from back during the Clone
Wars training her when she was younger
in this war you will face more than just
droids as your master
it's my responsibility to prepare you in
the way they explain this is that back
during the Clone Wars Anakin created 20
different Hollow recordings for Ahsoka
to train her should something happen to
him in battle but the thing was is that
he thought that he might die during the
Clone Wars at the time he didn't know
that he was going to turn into Darth
Vader turned to the dark side and he
didn't know Order 66 was about to happen
so the way they're explaining it
ahsoka's kept these and just listened to
them from time to time in the years
since order 66. it's kind of like Ahsoka
having a batch of home movies that
Anakin recorded for and just re-watching
them the way you re-watch home movies
every once in a while and because this
was happening during the Clone Wars he
was referencing a lot of events of the
Clone Wars he talks about General
Grievous asajj Ventress who was a member
of the Nightsisters race for everybody
wanting to see her in live action they
might eventually do that but it'd have
to be a serious set in the past if you
want to do live action Ventress because
she died during the events of the Clone
Wars or it would have to be some sort of
hologram or some kind of work around
Anakin mentions fighting Count Dooku and
the joke here is the osoka eventually
did face all of them in battle Skywalker
is not here to save you now the special
fighting forms Anakin is telling Ahsoka
to practice over and over are the
traditional Jedi fighting forms Baylan
skull would have taught them to Shin Hati
and I don't know if Ahsoka has taught
them completely to Sabine since her
whole thing was being a terrible student
in Ahsoka left her early in her training
so it just sounds like she hasn't got to
the point where she's learned all the
traditional Jedi forms later in the
episode when Ahsoka has her rematch with
Baylan Skoll they use some of the
traditional Jedi fighting forms the
other funny thing Dave filoni is doing
here behind the camera is letting us
know that there are at least 19 other
Anakin Skywalker cameos that they have
ready on the Shelf to fire off at a
moment's notice especially when Ahsoka
puts the one back in the box like oh we
have a whole bunch more Cameo scenes we
can watch here some of those they'll
probably save for like Ahsoka season 2
or like the Mandalorian season 4
wherever Ahsoka and Sabine wind up
showing up in future Series in the
future movies like we'll probably see
more Anakin Skywalker stuff during the
thrawn movie zoom in enhance on the
closet of all her supplies there like
she's got her box of the hollow
recordings that Anakin made for all of
her spare lightsabers in the training
helmet but she's also got a bunch of
classic training droids like the one
Luke Skywalker used on the Millennium
Falcon and the one he used to train
grogu recently with Ahsoka watching she
explains her whole plan to find Sabine
is by first locating where thrawn Morgan
Ellsworth the enemy are because she
understands that they'll be looking for
Sabine Ezra too so it's easier to find
where they are first and then search for
Sabine and Ezra they have a couple funny
moments with her making fun of who Yang
for being this stuffy Droid kind of like
C-3PO quoting the odds is a bit of a
reference back to the original trilogy
with C-3PO yelling at Han Solo never
quote me the odds I think the odds are
pretty good no no in fact that terrible
astronomically terrible sir the
possibility of successfully navigating
an asteroid field is approximately 3720
to watch never tell me the odds then we
find out what Morgan elsbeth did on
thrawn's orders to stop the purgles
basically a giant Imperial mine Fleet
around the planet so that when the
pergols dropped out of hyperspace it
would just start attacking them left and
right causing them to immediately jump
back into hyperspace stranding them on
the planet so they won't be able to use
the space whales to get back so now
Ahsoka Sabine Ezra's only way to get
back to the main Galaxy is either to
stow away on the hyperspace ring somehow
or allow themselves to get captured and
taken and it sounds like thrawn has no
interest in bringing them back so it
means that they would have to stow away
on the hyperspace ring there might be
some huge twists maybe the world Between
Worlds there's like a couple other ways
that they could surprise us with that
they make it back to the main Galaxy but
I think the idea is the ship Ahsoka ship
makes it back and it'd just be easier to
attach that to the hyperspace ring and
hide on their way back kind of like the
Millennium Falcon attaching itself to a
star destroyer so closely that its
sensors wouldn't pick it up you guys can
let me know in the comments how you
think that Ahsoka and everyone else
makes it back if they're going to bring
the back it just feels like the
only way to do that would be to attach
that to the hyperspace ring the small
ships that come after her inside the
field of debris from all the pergal
bones are Morgan L's best same
mercenaries with the same types of ships
that she fought earlier in the season
doing a little spacewalk taking out
ships in space using lightsabers in the
crazy other thing about the rings around
the planet here paridia is it seems like
most of the ring is actually made up of
dead pergal bones we get even more
Anakin Skywalker references when we jump
back to thrawn at the night sister
Temple he learns that ahsoka's Master
was Anakin Skywalker noticed his
reaction like he pauses for a second
like that look on his face he's
definitely taken aback
a master was General Anakin Skywalker
and if she's anything like her master
she'll be unpredictable and quite
dangerous
the reason why is because he knew Anakin
Skywalker became Darth Vader and he
worked with Darth Vader many times
inside the Empire on the emperor's
orders so it's one of the reasons why
he's so wary of Ahsoka because he
understands how powerful Darth Vader was
in that any Apprentice of his would also
be very powerful that's why he says if
she's anything like her master she'll be
dangerous and unpredictable which is
another order 66 Darth Vader reference
of this problem she could throw off
everything thrawn is all about
controlling all the variables in any
given situation which he talks about
when he's with Morgan elsbeth watching
the battle play out on his screen the
funny reason why Morgan ellisbeth
doesn't understand why thrawn is so
taken aback at the news of Anakin
Skywalker is that she didn't know that
Anakin became Darth Vader she just
thinks that he was a regular Jedi they
make another order 66 reference when he
says the Jedi have gotten very good at
hiding it's also a bit of a Star Wars
Rebels reference because Ahsoka Ezra
Kanan hid from him many times if you
didn't watch the Star Wars Rebels
episodes thrawn faced them many many
times like he's very familiar with
everybody that's on this show he
explains the reason why he's letting
Ahsoka go is to lull her into a false
sense of security so that she will give
herself away giving them another
opportunity to kill her making it way
easier for them this is meant to be an
example of his style of Battle Tactics
in his logic like that's one of his
greatest weapons is he's the greatest
military commander in the history of the
Galaxy so his mind is his superpower not
the force like he doesn't have the force
the same way but Dave filoni here wants
to show him going full Moriarty to make
a Sherlock reference or he is kind of
like an evil version of Sherlock Holmes
or a Sinister version of Sherlock Holmes
like a little colder which is ironic
because he was on Sherlock with Benedict
Cumberbatch we'll see more of thrawn's
style his mind Palace so to speak to
make another Sherlock reference in
future episodes and eventually the
thrawn movie basically showing him
wiping the floor with pretty much
anybody else he's in the room with when
hu Yang is wondering why they knew that
they were coming it's because of Soka
and don't know about the night sister's
ability to see forced visions of the
future in the past the strands of
Destiny so to speak like we sense the
Jedi is coming just another reference to
the dream like the way they perceive the
force there's a much longer scene with
Ezra and Sabine catching up with the
Krabs moving to a new location Sabine
basically gave him like the world's
biggest recap of the last nine years
worth of Star Wars story in the main
Galaxy the rise of the Rebellion because
Ezra disappeared right before A New Hope
the Galactic Civil War she mentions the
Battle of Endor the fall of the Empire
the perceived death of the emperor and
Darth Vader because Ezra faced both of
them both Palpatine and Vader she even
makes a small joke about Palpatine
coming back in the sequel Trilogy like
people think that he's dead people
mistakenly thinking that people died
when they actually survived is another
reference to Ahsoka not being dead when
Baylon Skoll season again like ah you
survived that's great probably also a
setup for the big night sister zombie
twist to the special cargo quote-unquote
that thrawn has been loading onto the
Star Destroyer they make a couple more
Star Wars Rebels references with Ezra
talking about the crew of The Ghost and
what happened to everybody since he's
been gone she explains what Zeb is doing
we saw him in that Cameo scene in the
Mandalorian he's training recruits maybe
we'll get another Cameo of him reuniting
with the crew of the ghost but they
might save that for the thrawn movie
notice how she avoids telling him the
whole truth about how she wound up here
finding him by giving baylen's goal the
star map allowing them to bring the
hyperspace ring so that thrawn could
return and start his new star war that's
what she means when she says things are
worse than her usual level of
complicated there's a lot of banter
between the two of them especially
during the battle later that's just
meant to be them referencing their
energy their banter together during Star
Wars Rebels they do a pretty decent job
of capturing the energy between the two
of them in the animated episodes but as
different actors playing them live
action probably one of the funniest
moments though is when they're going
back and forth and she tells them about
becoming ahsoka's Padawan he's like what
why would she do that like he couldn't
believe that Ahsoka would ever take her
on as a Padawan that's probably another
joke to like all the people out there
who just had trouble understanding what
was going on with being the first couple
of episodes like wait a minute is she
Force sensitive why is she such a
terrible Jedi with Ezra just making fun
of her a little bit just like in a nice
kind of way like he's like oh no no it's
great I'm wonderful I'm so happy for you
they referenced them both training
together with the dark saber during Star
Wars Rebels and obviously at this point
in the episode Sabine thinks that Ahsoka
isn't coming because she thinks that she
died falling off of the cliff she
doesn't know anything about the pergols
or the world Between Worlds mostly to
set up the payoff at the end when she
reunites with everyone like oh hey I
thought you were dead notice Baylan
skull and Shin Hati watching them on
their wolves the ironic thing here is
that they're actually named after Norse
wolves like Baylen skull and Shin Hati
are names of Norse wolves in mythology
then thrawn gets the Nightsisters use
their power to locate Ahsoka in the
force remember this main one is played
by Claudia Black from Farscape from a
bunch of other things like Stargate
you've probably seen her in at least
something they're calling her clotho all
three of the Nightsisters are named
after the three Greek faiths who could
perceive people's Destinies which are
kind of what these Nightsisters are
doing in the Star Wars Universe then
Ahsoka kind of does the the same version
of what the nice sisters are doing to
locate Sabine through their bond in the
forest now it's not the exact same
technique because night scissors have
different types of abilities different
ways of drawing on the force the normal
Jedi but it's very similar placing a
forced Skype call to Sabine Wren please
pick up the interesting thing here
though is that Ezra who we know is
actually pretty powerful in the force
can't sense Ahsoka calling Sabine it's
not like a wide area of effect kind of
force ability like it's a very direct
call they roll up on Baylan skull and
shin hot tea and the reason why he
orders her to kill them by herself with
the help of the mercenaries and then
join thrawn take her place back in the
new Empire is because he intends to stay
on the peridia planet he doesn't plan on
going back because he's searching for
that secret power that he says has been
calling to him it sounds like whatever
that power is it will allow him to
affect the entire universe so he doesn't
need to return to the main Galaxy so he
isn't that concerned with going back
like I said it could have something to
do with that zepho it could have
something to do with the world Between
Worlds it could be another opportunity
for an Anakin Cameo scene there are a
lot of people that have been asking me
in the last couple of videos I've been
posting about able off like is abelath
the person that he is searching for or
is calling to him because it leaves up
to presently that was meant to be a
non-canonical like Legends character
that was part of the mortise Gods so
like I just posted a video about how
Anakin Skywalker has replaced the
mortise Gods I'll link it at the end of
this but before the original mortise
Gods died there was the Father the Son
and the daughter and it was a Legends
book that sort of roped in the idea that
there was a mother at some point to a
human that served them but then drank
from this font of pure force and wound
up evolving into this chaotic evil force
being so if you've heard people talking
about Apple off on social that's why
thrawn sends two of his special Thai
gunships from Star Wars Rebels those are
just special TIE fighter variants of
gunships I've got a lot of questions
about Thai Defenders too like are there
any in the background there does he have
any on the Star Destroyer or the Chimera
there might be some Thai defenders in
there they might just be saving those
for the thrawn movie because thrawn was
behind the Thai Defender project in the
Canon version of Star Wars notice her
Ron's other plan here too is just a
stall Ahsoka and the others long enough
to complete their departure preparations
and then just recall his gunships when
it's time for them to jump to the
hyperspace ring to the main Galaxy just
stranding them back on the planet so he
doesn't actually care about killing
Ahsoka and the others like that would
just be a bonus for him the couple funny
moments when the battle actually begins
like the crap people shell up so to
speak but notice how sabine's howler is
a total coward like he refuses to leave
the shell there she was yelling at it in
last week's episode for doing the same
thing like you're a total coward when
Ahsoka enters the battle when she talks
to hu Yang about getting the timing
wrong it's meant to be a reference to
him not showing up to help her when she
was facing Baylan Skoll the last time
causing her to fall off the cliff like
he should have shown up a little bit
earlier so you could help me there are a
couple more funny moments between Ezra
and Sabine just showing their energy
bantering with each other like no no I
don't need the lightsaber I've got crazy
Force Powers now just more callbacks to
their banter during fights like this
during Star Wars Rebels and when we see
Ezra's new Force ability it's a little
bit like forced martial arts the
technique that they actually call
terracasi they canonize that during solo
Star Wars story and I don't think this
is actual tarikasi like that is an
actual genuine fighting form like the
traditional lightsaber fighting forums
but it's kind of what Ezra is doing and
it sounds like he's been developing this
technique because he hasn't had his
lightsaber these past nine years a lot
of people will ask how powerful Ezra is
compared to the other Jedi characters I
would say that he's not quite as
powerful as Ahsoka yet but he's about as
powerful as Kanan was during the events
of Star Wars Rebels speaking of Jedi
power scaling Ahsoka realizes she can't
defeat balen Skoll in lightsaber combat
they do have a bit of a rematch but she
uses huyang to distract him long enough
to get to Ezra and Sabine loved his
reaction to seeing Ahsoka again like he
is pleasantly surprised like he is
actually happy to see her like wow I'm
not even mad this is great that you're
here that's just another callback to his
whole thing not really hating Ahsoka or
the other Jedi because he doesn't want
to kill them off he doesn't want another
order 66 kind of situation it's all part
of this grand plan he has the secret
power on the planet that he's looking
for which we've referenced many times as
we're saving for the finale to actual
reveal what's really going on with that
that's why after she runs off like he
pauses for a second and gets really
distant looking off at something he's
feeling the call of that power and he
goes off to it so we'll find out in the
finale what's really going on kind of
annoying that they keep teasing that but
yet have revealed absolutely nothing
about what his plan is remember he wants
to stop all war which sounds like an
incredibly huge thing to do if it's
going to affect everything across the
entire universe that's why it might have
something to do with the world Between
Worlds and like this crazy power that
the Sith zepho had notice back at the
nice sister's Temple of thrawn also
clocks the Baylan skull isn't part of
the battle like ah what happened with
him like okay we'll answer in the next
episode the other really interesting
thing is that zoom and enhance on bailin
Skolls Gauntlet there he has the names
of a bunch of original trilogy
characters on there like C-3PO Chewie
Ben for Obi-Wan Kenobi Luke Leia but I
think that that's just meant to be an
Easter egg for the costume designers
behind the scenes like there's not meant
to be a special connection between
baylen's goal and all those original
Trilogy characters sometimes they'll
include Easter eggs like that they're
just meant to be gags behind the scenes
like not actual connections between
characters the night Troopers roll in we
get to see more of Ezra's Force powers
and then when thrawn says their battle
is almost like the Jedi of old when
Ahsoka rolls in he's talking about
watching what it looked like when a
bunch of Jedi would fight together
during the large battles against the
separatists during the Clone Wars right
on time though as predicted he recalls
his gunships because they're totally
ready to go like ah our only plan here
was to stall them long enough to load
the rest of the dead bodies that we're
going to raise into night sister zombies
the interesting thing though is that
Shin hati does not go back with the
night Trooper she stays behind and I
think it's because they want to tease
her developing a relationship with
Ahsoka the others like Shin Hati will
eventually wind up working with them
against thrawn at some point sort of
like a small Redemption Arc for her even
though we don't know that much about her
like we haven't had that many scenes
with her so we don't know much about
what happened to her backstory and what
her relationship with all the other
characters in the Star Wars Universe are
there's only one episode left so they're
probably not going to give us too big of
an info dump on her and Dave Floyd is
just like saving a bunch of those
reveals for the thrawn movie for like
the Mandalorian season 4 of Ahsoka
season two whatever they wind up
bringing the character back either way
this felt like the teaser for a Shin Hati
Redemption Arc there's a big reunion
with Ahsoka Sabine and Ezra hu Yang
shows up to pick them up and obviously
this is a big hanging plot thread like
the next episode is them finding out
what balen is really searching for this
power and how they're going to get home
like I said most likely scenario is that
they take Ahsoka ship and just attach it
or like dock it with the hyperspace ring
the other interesting thing is that if
you comb through the credits you notice
that Sam whitworth's name shows up again
under background voices meaning that he
also a voiced some more characters or
lesser characters in this episode my
guess is it was either some of the
background murmuring or maybe some of
the Droid characters post all your
theories in the comments below and if
there are any other Easter eggs or
references that you spotted in the
episode that I didn't talk about in the
video or plot points or questions that
you have just write them Below in the
comments I'll post an episode 8 finale
trailer video tomorrow and then
obviously my full episode 8 video will
post next week at they release it and
we'll learn a little bit more about
what's happening with Ahsoka season 2
just because the strike stuff is winding
down and they can actually start working
on Ahsoka season 2. big reminder though
that they do plan on doing the
Mandalorian season 4 before that I don't
know if they're going to be able to get
that out by the end of next year so it
might be like early 2025 before we get
that but that is supposed to come before
the thrawn movie so still a couple years
before that thrawn movie happens the
actual Next Big Star Wars series they're
doing is meant to be Skeleton Crew and I
actually think now based on what
happened on Ahsoka that a lot of that
series will take place in this other
Galaxy like they're meant to be stranded
on that ship with Jude Law's character
who's meant to be like a former Jedi but
I think it's going to happen in this
other Galaxy seriously though there's
like a whole giant Galaxy they just use
we've only seen one planet of course
they would want to explore that more in
other Star Wars series and if it wasn't
clear the Skeleton Crew show will cross
over with the Ahsoka series as well as
the Mandalorian series and those
characters will appear in the thrawn
movie as well Mando into the mandovers
like we have a Marvel situation going on
here with like all the Star Wars shows
crossing over and building up to their
version of Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game Star Wars end game but
I actually think that first thrawn movie
because they're basing this on the
original thrawn trilogy they'll just
call that movie heir to the Empire or
Star Wars Heir to the Empire click here
for that episode 8 finale video update
the link as soon as I post that and
click here to learn how Anakin replaced
the mortise gods in the Star Wars
Universe thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and this is the way!